In chapter 5 of One Piece, Zoro officially
accepted Luffy’s offer to join the crew.
And in only two years, this partnership would
lead them to become two of the strongest fighters
in the entire world.
But what if Zoro rejected Luffy’s offer
and never joined the straw hat crew?
Just how far would Luffy get on this journey?
And before we jump into changes in the story,
let’s actually take a look at the moment
that inspired this whole video, when Luffy
first invited Zoro to join the crew.
At this point, Zoro was tied to a post for
saving this little girl from these bad doggos.
Luffy then invited him to become the very
first crew member.
And you might not remember, but Zoro initially
refused.
However, when Luffy recovered his swords and
then freed the green moss head from his ropes,
he finally agreed to join the crew.
But obviously for this video, le’ts assume
that Zoro rejects Luffy a second time, slapping
away his invitation like a follow request
from a creepy stranger.
And if this were the case, Luffy could leave
Zoro tied up which would lead to him actually
being executed by the marines.
But honestly, another much more likely scenario
is that Luffy would still set Zoro free because
he knows deep down that Zoro is a good person.
So after defeating the marines, Zoro would
thank Luffy, but then simply walk away and
pursue his dream of becoming the world’s
strongest swordsman on his own.
And this will have massive consequences in
almost every part of the story.
Because as we see all throughout the story
and this video, when Luffy is on his own he
usually finds a way to get himself almost
killed.
*Wow*.
How is this guy going to become pirate king
anyway?
But now without Zoro, let's start with Wano
Country.
Wait… what?
Why are we starting so late in the story?
Well, since the point of this video is to
see how far the Straw Hats would get without
Zoro, it made sense to me to start at the
end and work our way backwards.
So we’ll be examining each of Zoro’s important
moments in the story and then seeing how things
would be different without him.
And because we are going in reverse order,
there won’t be any major storyline changes
like some of my previous what if videos.
So before we look at all of Zoro’s legendary
battles later on, let’s start early in the
arc.
He did have minor fights, like against this
straw man and in the battle to stop this former
daimyo's execution but in each of these conflicts
there were other straw hat’s present who
could’ve easily performed the same roles.
And not even counting the battles, his history
as a descendant of Wano literally never played
a role in the story, so even if he wasn’t
here the crew would’ve been just as motivated
to fight Kaido.
And this takes us to the climactic battles
of Onigashima.
Here Zoro was a major participant in the rooftop
battle against Big Mom and Kaido.
And his presence was definitely felt here.
He got in a few attacks, and blocked one of
the strongest attacks we have seen in the
entire story.
But ultimately, this battle was never really
decided either way, so did he really make
that big of a difference???
**shrug**
But next was his truly epic battle against
Kaido’s right hand man, King.
And while this was an incredibly hyped battle,
there are other characters nearby who probably
could’ve fought King as well.
In particular, Marco the Phoenix was not doing
much at all during this fight, so he could’ve
been a perfect match to fight the flying dinosaur.
Likewise, Luffy could have handled King no
problem once he was done with Kaido.
So as disappointing as it may sound, the straw
hats ultimately would have been fine in Wano
even without Zoro.
But I can promise you that will not be the
case for some of the arcs later on in the
story.
But since Zoro wasn’t in Whole Cake Island
at all, we’ll move ahead to Zou.
And on the back of this giant elephant, Zoro’s
fighting abilities weren’t really needed.
However, he did demonstrate one of his other
super important roles on the crew: his leadership.
When Sanji left to take care of his family
problems, Zoro told the rest of the crew that
Sanji better damn well apologize for his actions.
He left the crew at a super important time
in the story plus he was going to stir up
trouble with a second emperor.
And Zoro’s role here is important because
he is the only one who will really step up
and demand respect for the crew and its captain.
And while this tense moment didn’t result
in any major conflict, it was a good reminder
for Luffy about the honor and respect needed
on the crew.
But even if Zoro wasn’t here to give that
reminder, I don’t think it would have changed
Luffy’s actions much in Whole Cake Island.
However, that is definitely not the case for
another important moment coming up for the
crew later on.
So three arcs down and the Straw Hats would’ve
been just fine in each one.
Interesting…
Maybe one day if Zoro’s sense of direction
really got him lost, the crew would be just
fine.
But this brings us to Dressrosa, where Zoro
fought and defeated this giant stone man.
However, this is another enemy who isn’t
really all that powerful – I mean how could
he be with a voice like that – so someone
like Law, Sabo, or Luffy could have defeated
Pika almost instantly.
Moving back even further, Zoro does have a
moment in Punk Hazard when he yells at Luffy
after his captain almost died at the hands
of this gas man.
He demands that Luffy take things more seriously
and reminds them that they are in the most
dangerous part of the world now.
Of course, Luffy laughs it off so maybe it
wouldn’t matter even if Zoro was here to
remind his captain not to mess around.
Zoro also defeated this snow bird lady but
someone else could’ve easily taken her down
as well.
And this is going to bring us all the way
back to the time skip.
So as you can see, Zoro’s influence in the
post-time skip was not as important as you
might have previously thought.
And that’s because even though Zoro has
a fight in basically every arc, the crew is
not majorly challenged like they were in the
pre-time skip.
Plus everyone else is now super strong, so
Zoro isn’t one of the only strong fighters
in the crew.
Buuuutt, things are going to be way different
the further back we get in the story.
However, Zoro doesn’t play any role in the
events leading up to Marineford.
And even though straw hats were defeated on
Sabaody, Zoro’s absence wouldn’t really
have a major effect on the outcome anyway.
Now traveling back in time, let’s discuss
the nightmare-island, Thriller Bark, where
Zoro has HIS MOST BADASS MOMENT in the entire
story.
In his first fight of the arc, Zoro defeats
this zombie swordsman.
But I definitely think that Nightmare Luffy
could have also defeated the samurai.
But the even greater conflict came at the
end of the arc, when Zoro stood up to the
warlord Kuma to save Luffy.
In exchange for Luffy’s life, Zoro agreed
to take on all of his captain’s pain from
the previous battle.
And this resulted in the famous “Nothing
Happened” scene, which is personally one
of my favorites in the entire story.
But with Zoro not on the crew, it would fall
to Sanji to take on his captain’s pain.
I mean, Sanji already wanted to do this anyway
but Zoro knocked him aside.
So in this case, Sanji takes on all of the
pain, and we seriously have ask if he would
be able to survive this ordeal.
And Sanji stans don’t hate me, but I honestly
think the answer is no.
Zoro is shown all throughout the story to
have crazy endurance and the ability to fight
through pain.
So even though we have recently learned more
about Sanji's incredible body, I don’t think
that he could survive this crazy amount of
damage.
So sorry, Sanji…
Looks like you needed your moss head friend
after all.
But since we are now getting to the points
in the story where Zoro is absolutely needed,
I do want to add one major disclaimer.
Even though there will be a bunch of points
where Luffy would fail without Zoro, we can
usually find a reason for the straw hats to
continue.
For example, in this situation with Kuma,
it is possible the warlord takes mercy on
them because he is friends with Luffy’s
father after all.
So while we can usually find an excuse, there
are some arcs that are just impossible to
move on from without Zoro.
And this brings us to the government’s judicial
island, Enies Lobby.
During this arc, we see one of the three major
characteristics that Zoro brings to the crew.
Two of these we will discuss coming up very
soon, but the first characteristic is that
he is just a badass fighter.
At this point in the story, he, Luffy, and
Sanji are the only strong ones who can really
fight – no offense Nami and Robin.
And Chopper loses his mind when he goes berserk.
So Zoro’s absence is a major problem when
Luffy is somehow distracted or taken out because
then there is no one left to protect the others.
And this situation happens in basically every
arc.
But maybe that means that Luffy would take
things more seriously, so he doesn’t put
the rest of the crew in danger.
Buuut…
I kinda doubt it.
So let’s keep this in mind as we shift back
to Zoro’s fight against this sword-wielding
giraffe.
Zoro eventually wins this battle and claims
key number 5 which is the exact key needed
to free Robin from her handcuffs, so without
Zoro winning this fight, Robin would be trapped
for good.
However, I do think someone else like Luffy
or Sanji could have defeated the giraffe man,
so in the end Robin
would
still be free.
However, moving back to Water 7, we get another
critical example of how without Zoro’s presence
as the unofficial Vice-Captain, the crew would
surely fall apart.
So the crew reached Water 7 in need of a new
ship.
This of course sparks the fierce duel between
Usopp and Luffy, which results in Usopp leaving
the crew.
And this is an incredibly important moment
for the crew’s long term future.
And that’s BECAUSE IF Luffy gave in to Usopp’s
demands, it would have shown the crew that
Luffy is not a strong captain and he is not
worthy of their faith.
However, in chapter 333, Zoro will not let
Luffy take the easy route and he reminds Luffy
that making these difficult choices are the
burden of being the captain.
But without Zoro in this scene, Luffy may
very well have chosen to keep Usopp’s friendship
rather than do what was best for the crew.
And if Luffy let Usopp rejoin the crew or
agreed to keep using their ship, it could
have disastrous consequences later on.
For example, if they did keep using the Merry,
it could have sunk in the middle of the ocean.
Or if Luffy didn’t earn the respect of the
crew in this scene, they may not always listen
to his orders later on.
And this lack of respect and leadership could
eventually lead to a tragic breakup during
some future conflict.
So here we have our first true example of
Zoro’s importance to the crew.
Because I really don’t think that anyone
else on the crew is as serious and devoted
to respect to have the same kind of impact
as Vice-Captain.
Sanji is kinda wishy-washy.
Usopp has his moments, but is too weak.
And Nami would rather avoid these kinds of
serious issues within the crew.
And besides his fighting and leadership qualities,
there is even a third characteristic that
no one else on the crew possesses.
Out of all the straw hats, Zoro is the one
most single-mindedly focused on his goal of
becoming the world’s strongest swordsmen.
It is pretty much the easiest goal to understand.
It probably sounds a little bit like this
in Zoro’s mind: Get stronger.
Defeat enemies.
Simple, right?
But Zoro is also the only one we consistently
see training to reach his goals.
He is frequently lifting weights or practicing
his sword skills, and I like to think that
this has some effect on the crew as well.
So we have to wonder if losing Zoro would
make the crew less dedicated towards their
goals.
I think Luffy would still of course want to
be pirate king, but as you’ll see in just
a moment, Zoro’s was truly irreplaceable
in the early parts of the story.
Plus, if Zoro’s not there to butt heads
with Sanji, then the cook’s pervertedness
might reach even more ridiculous heights.
Who knows Nami could even kill Sanji herself
if he peeps in on her bath one too many times.
But now onto Skypiea, where Zoro plays a key
role in the outcome of the arc His first major
action was when he defeated this winged puppy
lover.
And while there was no one else around to
really take this guy out, I can imagine Luffy
defeating him pretty easily once he got out
of the snake.
And after this, none of the surviving characters
can defeat the lightning god Enel, so Zoro
basically takes a nap until he helps cut down
the giant beanstalk.
So without Zoro it is possible the beanstalk
never gets cut down, which means Luffy would
have not reached Enel in time to deliver the
final blow.
But I think between this warrior’s dedication
and Nami’s cleverness, they would have found
some way to get Luffy to Enel.
But this brings us to Alabasta and the juicy
bits of this video.
Zoro’s main role in the arc is to take down
the warlord Crocodile’s right hand man,
Mr. 1.
And originally, this was a huge moment of
growth for Zoro as he finally learned how
to cut steel.
Kinda crazy, actually that he couldn’t even
do that up until this point in the story.
But with Zoro out of the picture, someone
else needs to stop this insane blade man from
tearing through the crew.
Certainly, I think Luffy could eventually
figure out a way to beat Mr. 1, even though
Luffy and sharp things don’t get along too
well.
But Luffy already had his hands full with
Crocodile, so someone else would need to take
out Mr. 1 or distract Croc-man – or mom
– while Luffy takes out Mr. Blades.
And I think their best chance is a combination
of Sanji and Nami, where Sanji could keep
Mr. 1 busy while Nami figures out how to strike
him with lightning.
But that’s not the only critical role Zoro
plays.
He is also part of the team that helps Vivi
reach the bomb, and without Zoro to fling
Chopper and Vivi into the air, they would
have to come up with another plan to reach
the top.
Perhaps Usopp could quickly make a giant slingshot,
or another option is the marine captain Smoker
could help by using his Smoke logia powers
to get them up to the bomb.
And you might be asking why would Smoker help
them out, but I certainly don’t think the
marine captain would just stand around if
he knew that millions could die from a giant
bomb.
Plus these are desperate times without our
favorite swordsman, so we’ve gotta be a
little creative here.
So after Luffy defeats Crocodile, the straw
hats get their next major bounties.
And without Zoro to take much of the credit,
the rest of the straw hats get a pretty good
bump in each of their bounties.
Which is great for Sanji, Usopp, and maybe
Chopper finally gets the respect he deserves,
but Nami is certainly not pleased with this
turn of events.
So as punishment, she demands that you subscribe
to the channel for more one piece content
just like this.
Let’s jump out of the desert now, and continue
moving backwards.
Certainly, the straw hats would be just fine
in Little Garden and Drum Island, since Zoro
basically just got stuck in wax and then decided
to have a little winter time workout in the
snow.
But this brings us to the booze-lovers favorite
island, Whiskey Peak.
Here the straw hats were tricked into passing
out drunk and then the entire island tried
to capture them to earn bounty money.
However, Zoro was sober enough to fight them
off until Luffy and the others woke up.
So while Zoro did a lot of work here, none
of these enemies were super powerful, so I
think Luffy and the others would have eventually
gotten free no matter what.
So as hard as it is to believe, over nine
hundred chapters in reverse and we’ve only
had one real moment where Zoro’s absence
could have led to an eventual break up, and
a few others that required creative solutions
for the crew to advance.
But no absolute crushing defeats.
And next is the East Blue!
The weakest Sea of all.
It should be a walk in the park for the straw
hats… right?
Right???
Well, let’s see if they can survive Arlong
Park.
Here the straw hats will again be missing
Zoro’s fierce loyalty to the crew.
Because in chapter 71, Zoro confronts Nami
in front of this gang of Fishmen.
And here Nami is still pretending that she
doesn’t care about the crew, but Zoro does
not believe her AT ALL.
In fact, to prove that she still belongs with
the crew, he throws himself into the water.
This forces Nami to choose to let him drown
or save him herself.
Of course Nami saves him, which proves to
both Zoro AND Nami that she still cares about
the crew.
So without Zoro here, this entire arc could
play out very differently.
Nami may not be as convinced about her true
feelings for the straw hats, or at least it
may take her longer to finally break down
and accept help.
But beyond the emotional stakes, Zoro also
played a significant role in the fights in
Arlong Park.
Because even though he was still seriously
injured from his early battles – more on
that very soon – he fought off this sword-wielding
octopus and even kept the fishman’s captain
Arlong busy when Luffy was trapped underwater.
So without Zoro, someone else like Sanji would
need to step in to fight Arlong until Luffy
was rescued.
And this presents all kinds of major challenges,
since Sanji was the one to fight who broke
the rock Luffy was trapped in.
So either someone else would have to keep
Arlong busy – sorry Usopp – or someone
else would need to free Luffy, but I truly
don’t know who else here is strong enough
to do that.
So again, this is our first clear example
where Luffy could have very easily died without
Zoro’s help.
But let’s imagine that Sanji does fight
off Arlong long enough for Luffy to be freed
by Usopp, who heroically blasts the rock off
of Luffy’s legs with a cannon.
So with Luffy free, he can defeat Arlong and
rescue Nami’s village for good.
Another narrow escape, but the same cannot
be said of the Baratie, where there is literally
nothing the straw hats can do on their own
to survive.
But let’s not get ahead of ourselves.
First, it is possible that they will never
find Sanji’s floating restaurant at all.
Because in chapter 42, the straw hat’s new
ship is attacked by everyone’s favorite
bounty hunters, Johnny and Yosaku.
Luffy is ready to kick them off the ship,
but then Zoro recognizes Johnny and they quickly
become friends and get directions to the Baratie.
However if Zoro was not on board, Luffy might’ve
just thrown them overboard.
This could lead to them never finding the
Baratie, which of course means no Sanji.
However, there are some other possibilities
that could still lead them to Sanji.
First, Luffy might want to recruit these bounty
hunting bros since he still needs a strong
fighter.
Or even if he doesn’t they could find out
about the floating restaurant from someone
else on another island.
So let’s assume that they just find the
Baratie somehow, where they are 100% going
to be destroyed without Zoro.
And after destroying part of the restaurant,
Luffy is forced to work as a chore boy to
pay off the damage.
That is until this pirate commodore eventually
shows up and starts shooting up the place.
And Zoro’s role in this fight is basically
zero.
However, when the world’s strongest swordsman,
Mihawk, makes his appearance things completely
change.
You see, originally, Mihawk came to the restaurant
intent on taking down the very same pirates
who were now attacking the restaurant.
And after Mihawk easily cuts their giant ship
in half, Zoro steps up to challenge the warlord.
And even though Zoro is utterly defeated,
Mihawk is so impressed by Zoro’s honor as
a swordsman and his loyalty to Luffy, that
he decides to leave everyone else alone.
And this scene perfectly shows off something
only Zoro brings to the crew.
He is fiercely honorable.
While Luffy, Nami, and Usopp will use every
trick in the book to defeat an enemy, Zoro
will face an opponent head on in an honest
duel.
He is also intensely loyal to the crew, so
much that he places Luffy’s dream’s ahead
of his own.
And it is these very traits that so inspire
Mihawk to let everyone else live.
But without Zoro on the crew, there is no
telling what Mihawk would do to the Straw
Hats.
Would Mihawk be satisfied just taking this
guy’s head?
Maybe.
Or would he want to continue to eliminate
all of the pirates at the restaurant?
And if Mihawk were to come after Luffy, then
our rubber man has absolutely no chance against
the world’s strongest swordsman.
So the straw hats’ fate would be entirely
out of their hands.
But let’s say that Mihawk is feeling generous.
Or maybe the head chef Zeff convinces him
to spare Luffy because he still needs to work
off his debt.
Or, come on let’s be honest, this introvert
just wants to return to his dark castle.
But without Zoro, this would definitely be
a time the Straw Hats could’ve been wiped
out.
And that’s even more true in the arc before
this, Syrup Village.
So back up to chapter 23, with Luffy, Zoro,
and Nami sailing to Usopp’s home island.
And now that Nami is steering the ship, the
risk of death at sea is basically none.
So the trio travel to Syrup village, where
they meet the boy who cried wolf, Usopp.
And Zoro’s role in this arc is minimal until
the final battle, where he fights these feline
brothers.
And at this point in the fight, Luffy was
hypnotized and asleep, so unless Nami woke
him up, they would all be in serious trouble.
So it is entirely possible that the crew is
taken out because Luffy was tricked into a
situation where he cannot help himself of
the crew.
*looks down dejectedly* Wow, these guys really
need Zoro.
But of course, we could imagine that somehow
they make it out alive.
Maybe Luffy never gets put to sleep or that
Nami is able to wake him up earlier.
Or maybe Usopp shoots him with some smelling
salts – speaking of which, wow those things
are powerful.
But with this one I really don’t think they
would have been able to survive.
I mean without Zoro, Luffy is literally the
only strong fighter.
So once again, the Straw Hats journey is at
its end.
But let’s take another step back to Orange
Town, and see how Luffy would do in the first
arc without Zoro.
In this small village, Luffy first meets Nami.
Since Zoro isn’t even on the island yet,
Luffy is still captured by Buggy the Clown.
So Luffy is locked in a cage.
He is about to be blasted by Buggy’s special
cannon balls.
However, in chapter 11, he is saved when Zoro
fights off Buggy and then flips the cannon
away from Luffy.
Zoro then carries Luffy’s cage away from
Buggy and into the town.
However, with no Zoro, Luffy is basically
helpless.
Nami already tried to save him, but she was
no match against Buggy’s crew.
So unless Luffy was able to somehow chew his
way out of the cage, his pirate adventure
is over after just a single island without
Zoro.
*Take a deep breath.* Damn, that’s actually
kinda sad.
But all that just proves what Luffy has said
all along.
He truly wouldn’t be able to do anything
without his crew.
But while Luffy’s journey without Zoro is
basically over after just one island, that
means the other straw hats never get to pursue
their dreams as part of the crew.
And this brings us to an even more interesting
question.
What would happen to everyone else in the
story, if Luffy was never born?
And if you want to watch that video, you can
click right here.
Shanks for watching.